we noticed that the crucifixion in
Mark's Gospel is quite different that it
is especially in Luke and John because
the sheer starkness of the way in which
Jesus dies with no kind of final words
of forgiveness or farewell or trust but
just my God my God why have you forsaken
me
one reason that the Gospel of Mark has
puzzled lots of people is that the
resurrection also seems to end the
resurrection story chapter 16 seems to
end
oddly what's going on there it's we get
an empty tomb but nobody to tell about
it
and so 16-8 the last words of the gospel
are the woman went away and didn't tell
anybody because they were afraid all
right so everything toward which this
gospel has been building including the
climax of the of the cross ends up
resting on how these people are going to
respond to this resurrection and
nobody's going to hear about it at least
at the end of a 16-8 it's the great
great puzzle it's what keeps you and me
reading right it's the great puzzle of
Mark's Gospel and everybody's tried to
help him right copyists tried to help
him and put a little more on the end so
that it would be a little more like
Matthew or more likely so so just the
endings are being older than you grew up
with the King James Bible and King James
Bible did not end with chapter 16 verse
8 it ended with chapter 16 verse 20 and
he appears several times and he deals
with Mary Magdalene and does many
wonderful things but you're saying
that's not the earlier copy right and
it's it's consensus as close as you get
to consensus among scholars that 16-8
would have been the ending because it's
it's the most represented in the
manuscripts and also because it it it
makes the least sense yeah which means
copyists seem to be trying to help it
out yeah yeah and and you know what that
leaves us with having lived 16 chapters
or 15 prior chapter is a lot of
unfinished business that when we get to
the end of 16 eight if we're in an
audience listening to this feels like
it's not yet done yeah part of
that is because we come to it having
heard other Gospels right so of course
oh Jesus isn't gonna make breakfast
Cathy I know she's supposed to be there
yeah and and so we we partly get our
expectations elsewhere but there are
plenty in Mark's Gospel to have us
thinking is this really over yeah at the
end because back in Chapter one a little
thing back in Chapter one John the
Baptist announced Jesus by saying one is
coming after me who's mightier than I am
and that one will baptize you with the
Holy Spirit we haven't seen where that's
right we haven't seen any of it and
throughout the gospel we have the
expectation that at some point some
disciple is going to get what the
narrator in 1:1 and God at the Baptism
and at the Transfiguration and the
demons and then Jesus at his own trial
all know which is and then finally the
Centurion all know which is that this is
the son of God and none of them in the
course of 16 chapters have yet gotten it
yeah we also expected that they would
somehow come back around to
understanding that this denying of self
that Jesus called for accessory and
Philip I to Peter this take up your
cross and follow me let him deny himself
that this will somehow sink in some time
and it hasn't yeah through three passing
predictions they just keep not getting
yeah and so by that by the end of this
and and you reminded me earlier in this
this afternoon that in the
Transfiguration we hear they won't get
this until after the resurrection
there's nobody there to get 16-8 so so
there's a hole there a whole lot of
loops that haven't been closed in the
world of the gospel not just in our
expectations because we know more than
this gospel in the world of the gospel
at the end of 68 and I think that's
Mark's sort of clever way of doing
something that you brought up a long
time ago in these in these conversations
which is saying this is the beginning of
the gospel of Jesus Christ the Son of
God because if I'm in if I'm in a room
listening to this
and I have come in as we talked about
earlier saying I'm gonna watch those
disciples because those disciples are
mighty too right I need to pray for it
and you know if pay pious is right this
is happening in Rome and we may be in
post Nero times yeah right
but doesn't need to be that we see in
chapter 13 they're expecting
persecutions and maybe experiencing them
what they need is courageous disciples
and so they listen the whole time to see
what they're supposed to look like and
they don't get it at the end of the
gospel they still have it on it and so I
imagine this silence in the room
afterwards is sort of disappointed
almost angry silence in which they are
looking for how are we going to where
are we gonna hang our hat yeah and then
someone remembers wait a second we know
Peter went on mmm-hmm to do to do
martyrdom yeah yeah we know we know
these guys and the stories start to fly
yeah we know these guys eventually God
is not the end of the it's not the end
of those this is the end of the written
story is not the end of the gospel it's
the end of the beginning is the end of
the begin right and and and so that
moment of recognition asks raises the
next question which is how how did they
change from these sniveling guys yeah
that we see running away with every
chance to to the courageous ones who we
know about from from stories around
campfires and and and in that moment
they are I think driven to realize that
whether the women running what ran away
afraid from the tomb or not somehow
Jesus found these guys and they
experienced the risen Christ they got
what Holy Spirit baptism they understood
at some point what this downward
direction of discipleship looked like in
because otherwise we don't end up with
the the Apostles that they knew from the
disciples or all material that makes
sense it does make sense I it makes
sense doesn't mean I'm happy with the
solution to the puzzle entirely because
it still puzzles me the the most recent
kind of illustration I've had in my own
reading that helps a little bit and it's
it's reverse in terms of
being further tragedy not greater
triumph at the end of the story but I've
been reading Wolf Hall which is the new
retelling of the Anne Boleyn and we the
eight story through the eyes of Thomas
Cromwell and it ends with Anne Boleyn
still alive well and as happy as one can
be with Henry the eighth as a husband
which is not very happy as a matter of
fact but we know what the story won't in
the story world that's the end of the
story we living in a world beyond know
that she's the next to go and that that
Henry the eighth who's wandering off to
see Jane Seymour that weekend will
choose Jane as the next lucky recipient
of his affections and the novel is
richer because we know a history behind
the novel right I think in some ways the
Gospel of Mark is richer because we know
that the end of that story told is not
the end of the story lived right that
this is a transition from the way the
story begins to the way the story goes
on I've also always often long suspected
recently suspected that the Silence of
the women is not only contrasted with
what must happen to them in a bitter
sobs later it's contrasted with us we
tell all right you guys go tell right
right if we were left to those silent
first generation we might not make it
but now we in 70 AD 68 80 whatever it is
we're in the business of telling this
story we're not invited to silence and
2010 82,000 yeah and I I think you know
we've we've marked along the way we've
noted along the way Marx cleverness and
and how much we see him arraying things
so that messages come from more than
just individual you day of a paragraph
and we we therefore can look back and
ask are there hints we saw side by side
to synagogue healings and we compared
them we saw side-by-side to bred
miracles and we compared them and Mark
seemed to want us to compare the right I
don't know this this is sort of I don't
know whether this is Advanced Placement
listening for in early Christian crowd
or for a contemporary crowd whether it's
it's making mark over clever but in in
chapter 8 just before the scene
accessory of film
you get this very strange episode that
the other Gospels don't want to repeat
in which jesus heals a man of his
blindness in two stages right right and
if we sit with mark long enough we
realize that we when something weird
happens we ought to watch it and see if
there's a message out there there's a
first stage in which Jesus puts mud on
the guy's eye and asked can you see and
the guy says I can see but it's like
trees walking around right
people are like trees watering around
and then he cleanses his eyes anding see
fully yeah that comes just before Jesus
and and Peter accesory of Philip I word
where Peter says you're the Messiah and
essentially Jesus quietly says you're
right and then not right enough and and
then Jesus says I'm gonna die and Peter
says no yeah so Peters wrong so we got
past vision he sees he sees people like
trees walking along which which means
that it's another one of these bits that
tries to set an expectation yeah that
isn't realized in the pages of the
gospel through 16/8 if that's the case
and again who knows if that gets tracked
when I get to sixteen eight and I'm in
an ancient I know listening audience do
I look back and say aha yeah that's
that's well what's happening in eight
but for those of us who get the luxury
of going back and looking at it over and
over and reading it that's awfully nice
yeah it signals something that gives
hope that 16/8 is in the last word which
we know the other the other theme that
does that for me and i just confess i've
stopped worrying as much about what the
first entry heard then i used to because
it's unanswerable just among the things
I'll never know or what did a first
century audience hear when they hear
that thank you sweet or Liberty say now
that I've seen it it must be there right
so now that I've seen this this must be
there and if they missed it I'll ask for
them but how often the theme of fear
comes up in this gospel and the very
last thing that happens with these women
in mark 16 is they're afraid
the next to the last word is afraid and
the last word is because which is almost
mid-sentence not even here not just mid
thug had been sentenced up time and
again Jesus contrasts faith with fear
and says don't be fearful only have
faith and the one I remember most
clearly is when he's walking across the
sea and they're terrified and just when
they're most afraid he joins them in the
boat and comforts them and my strong
suspicion for a long time has been that
if we read Mark's Gospel through seeing
that fear is always contrasted with
faith and comes just before promised
that we know fear can't be the last word
now either that there's that next word
which lies beyond the words on the page
and that has to do with faith and
comfort and reappearance yeah yeah
that's and now you're to I mean at the
beginning of these sessions you asked me
why do I keep reading this guy yeah and
I gave an answer about how quickly
things come at us and and that's part of
it and I gave an answer about how
quickly Jesus starts to reveal who he is
through actions instead of words and
that's part of it but when you get to
the end of the day what this gospel does
is it lays out the possibility that God
can help us amidst those myriad fears we
have that that that God never lets fear
be the little word and it's true on the
cross right right and it's true in the
resurrection together and and so at the
end of the day that the answer deepens
to why should we keep reading this book
why why is it helpful for the church
there's a profound message of help
there's a profound message that the
things that seem final and thwarting are
not so that's that's a good reason but I
think you can't get better news than
that let's stop